it is world autism month advocates and
parents across the valley want to raise
more awareness about the condition
bianca holman joining us live with how
one doctor is stepping up and bianca
making a bit of a difference good
morning hey good morning heather so it's
currently estimated that as many as 8
500 school-aged children in nevada are
diagnosed with autism spectrum disorder
many living right here in the valley so
we spoke with a local pediatric
neurologist and her name is dr roman
ahad and she actually works with
autistic children daily she recently
wrote a book titled amazing abe has
autism it follows a young boy named abe
to everyday life activities with his
family on the playground and with his
speech therapist it helps show
how he is just like other children and
also how he's different the book
also is not just for children with
autism it's also for those who for
children who have a relative or a loved
one that has autism
i thought there just wasn't a literary
space for a book written by a physician
who actually experiences it from a
different perspective
and so that's really where the book idea
came from
i also just wanted to create some
literary space for children on the
spectrum to help them
help others understand them better
dr ahad works with grant a gift autism
foundation and unlv school of medicine
the book has been well received and she
has some upcoming book readings as well
amazing abe has all has autism is
available um now online on barnes noble
and amazon and coming up in the next
half hour we will have more information
about autism awareness month and
resources here in the valley bianca
holman live local now